welcome back to come with me Josh Smith
and today we're joined by the living
legend times uh vo Colin Farrell her
amazing paper green the cutest cast on
the planet this is done by guys
I pretty much ugly cried for ninety
minutes straight during this film yeah
and I wish no what type of cry are you
oh yeah are you a single solitary cry
I'm not kind of like I try to hide it
cry during on the plane I have no shame
I cry all the time there's something
with the altitude be a bit of a shame
crier sometimes I know yeah I'd be
covering the face a little bit for fear
that I'm an ugly crier I can vacillate
between having a gentle weep but a good
shoulder shrugging boohoo you know you
look into those eyes numbers eyes my
goodness it's just like you're melt
the premiere was in Los Angeles was
sponsored by Kleenex very clever
you gonna create a circus boot camp and
I was gonna enroll in there yeah
what would kind of train would you put I
know can you type ropewalk have you ever
done it I think it would be great
yeah maybe this could be sang I could
practice but yeah yeah as they say no
pain no gain
just put the Rope really low I was
living for all the tricks that you're
doing in there first of all you need to
be super strong you need to get some
very strong abs because you have to kind
of do some hiking position I mean it's
quite you know you in you have to do
lots of weird flips and stuff and you
have to pull yourself as well I have to
say though I think I might just think to
be in the clown because that sounds like
a lot of what F in a gym yes but then is
very empowering there's something quite
magical but that you you feel like
you're never gonna make it work and then
one day that's it no I was just
wondering because obviously Dumbo flies
with his ears would you prefer to have
ears that could fly that are always that
size and nose that would extend to a
trunk every time you lie or like an
elephant never be able to forget
anything ever I'm never able to forget
anything ever might be a torture the
trunk would get bigger every time I lied
hmm
this is a program that goes on
television
okay well I'm gonna go to ears I'm gonna
go to ears that I can fly anywhere I
want
I'd be alright in with big ears in the
social ridicule that would inevitably
come my way if I could take flight yeah
I would go to Jersey with my ears when I
would look those guys New Jersey friends
imagine if I rolled in Asbury Park
flying with oh my god that would be so
great I want to be Dumbo well hop most
heartbreaking - this is when Dumbo gets
turned into a clown yeah that's really
sad because mainly because no one likes
to see a bad makeover have you ever in
your life had a bad makeover and how
have you recovered from it I mean first
of all I like Dumba's makeup as a clown
that's right Tim Burton the my question
like that I know he's yep anyway that's
the other thing I don't know you know
when I was like 16 I was in the American
school in in Paris and every day was a
fashion show I don't know because I used
to be in the French system before so
there was no makeup but it was I was not
expressing myself really and when I got
into the American system I was like yeah
so every day I'm gonna put like purple
eyeshadow a bit of purple lipstick here
like a purple bow the next day the green
green I mean it was like it was like a
teenage crisis probably it's like Gossip
Girl on steroids that yeah how
mischievous are you guys
what was the top ranked Oh stealing
people's ID I forgot we would go around
and like snatch people's like we were
just like things we'd steal Miko did it
at first and then she taught me and we
were like ninjas we used to take it no
one noticed my stealth ninjas yeah one
of the most amazing things to take away
from this as well as about celebrating
difference what would you say to someone
who is probably suffering from feeling
isolated because of their difference
what kind of empowering mantra would you
want to give to them you know it's okay
to be to feel a bit strange to not fit
in you know just embrace who you are
embrace your your uniqueness and
it will make you actually quite
beautiful and special but everyone is
different enough is a billion of us
nearly on the planet and there's no
tools that are the same so you know I
think self-acceptance is a huge thing
and it's a very hard thing for most
human beings and something that we all
struggle with and I struggle with and
and yeah the more one can accept that
one is perfect just as one is and and
it's not really for the world to tell us
our worth ever we have to kind of find
it from inside it is important to have
community it is important to have people
we can lean on and people that love us
and respect us absolutely but the more
we can give that love and respect and
attention to ourselves you know the
better yes fingers fix it up